[Música]
y
en ecuador al uso de la vitamina c se ha
promovido como una tendencia de un
supuesto protector ante el 19 a pesar
que los especialistas aseguran que el
uso de la vitamina se produce beneficios
en la respuesta inmune del organismo lo
cierto es que ratifican que no hay base
técnica ni científica para afirmar su
efectividad ante el hobbit 19 luego de
seis meses de emergencias sanitarias el
país
andinos los especialistas sólo apuestan
por el lavado de manos el
distanciamiento social y el uso de
mascarillas como medidas de protección
ante la pandemia cuestionan esta
tendencia con una estrategia de mercado
de farmacias y vendedores particulares
para generar falsas esperanzas frente a
una enfermedad que afecta de forma
severa sin vacuna específica a sociedad
busca desesperadamente seguridad por
ello alertaron que el incremento de
contagios está relacionado a los
contactos sociales y no dudaron que se
incrementarán los casos positivos desde
el 13 de septiembre cuando concluya el
estado de sección en ecuador y se
flexibilicen las medidas de restricción
[Música]
venezuela que cuenta con un sistema de
salud pobre y donde escasean los
medicamentos
el protocolo terapéutico para el hobby
19 se ha paseado por cuestionados
tratamientos hasta curas milagrosas
emitidas por el gobierno de nicolás
maduro en este momento las personas
infectadas reciben un kit con el
polémico antiparasitario invermet inah
además del medicamento cubano
experimental interferón y la criticada
hidro cloro
a esteroides aspirina y a vitamina c los
últimos dos meses el gobierno de nicolás
maduro también ha usado el plasma como
tratamiento para curar el cobit que
aunque no ha sido comprobado
mundialmente ellos siguen pidiendo a las
personas recuperadas que donen el suero
también hay que resaltar que cuando
comenzó la pandemia nicolás maduró
sugirió a las personas que se prepararan
brebajes con malojillo y jengibre además
que podían usar homeopatía y el polémico
dióxido de cloruro
[Música]
en bolivia el uso del dióxido de cloro
para tratar a pacientes con coronavirus
está bastante extendido pese a que las
autoridades y la organización
panamericana de la salud han advertido
de los efectos adversos para la salud e
incluso se han visto filas de ciudadanos
en los puntos donde se expende el
dióxido de cloro y se sabe que son los
médicos quienes prescriben esta
sustancia a los enfermos de kobe 19
quienes promueven su uso afirman que
existe un complot internacional de
farmacéuticas y gobiernos en contra de
una sustancia que es barata y de fácil
acceso para la gente pobre incluso en el
país existe una polémica política pues
si bien el gobierno de jeanine áñez ha
prohibido su uso e incluso ha amenazado
con procesar a quienes lo promueven la
asamblea legislativa que está dominada
por el partido del ex presidente evo
morales ha aprobado una ley en sentido
contrario que establece que el estado
debe promover el uso del dióxido de
cloro a través de sus instituciones
públicas ante la polémica el gobierno ha
enviado la ley en consulta ante el
tribunal constitucional
[Música]